The correct answer is 5 times root 5 plus 10. Nice thinking if you got it. This
would be an alternate form of the correct answer as well. You could have
factored a 5 from each of these terms to have 5 times the square root of 5 plus
2. Keep in mind that you need parenthesis around this entire quantity since
you're distributing the 5 to each of hte terms. We start rationalizing this
denominator by multiplying the numerator and the denominator by the conjugate.
The conjugate of root 5 minus 2 is root 5 plus 2. We distribute the 5 to each
of these terms to get 5 root 5 plus 10 in our numerator. For the denominator
we'll use the difference of squares pattern to do a squared minus b squared.
The A is route 5 and the B is positive 2. This leaves us with 5 minus 4 in our
denominator. 5 minus 4 equals 1 and anything divided by 1 is itself. So we're
left with our final answer.